we'll begin with this leaders from
around the world of starting two days of
observances to remember the 75th
anniversary of d-day president Trump and
Queen Elizabeth are part of this morning
ceremony in Portsmouth England one of
the main departure points for the world
war two invasion of german-occupied
France German Chancellor Angela Merkel
is also there along with representatives
from all 14 Allied nations that took
part in d-day president Trump read a
prayer that Franklin Franklin Roosevelt
delivered to the nation over the radio
on d-day Anthony Mason is in Normandy
France at a cemetery where thousands of
American troops are buried Anthony good
morning good morning this is in fact my
third time visiting the American
Cemetery here in Normandy which is just
the Omaha Beach is just beyond those
headstones and and honestly I'm always
struck by the gravity and enormity of
what happened here it's almost
incomprehensible behind me you can see
some of the perfectly aligned American
graves there are 9380 headstones here
many of the servicemen buried in this
cemetery died during the d-day invasion
in fact that number 9380 is only a third
of the americans lost in the Battle of
Normandy their headstones are all facing
home toward the US on our way in this
morning we got a sense of some of the
enthusiasm here in Normandy we drove
past military vehicles many of them
flying American and French flags this is
a community that has always embraced and
honored those who sacrificed for their
freedom d-day was the largest military
operation ever attempted more than a
hundred and fifty thousand Allied troops
landed on the beaches of Normandy on
June 6 1944 that marked the start of the
campaign to liberate Nazi occupied
Europe the invasion was initially
planned for 75 years ago today but was
delayed 24 hours because of bad weather
fittingly scattered showers are expected
today as well the events of today and
tomorrow will be one of the last
opportunities to honor those who fought
in World War two with veterans still
alive
of the more than 16 million Americans
who served fewer than half a million are
still with us most well into their 90's
now as many as 100 vets are expected to
be here for tomorrow morning ceremony
which is expected to last just over an
hour the President and First Lady will
be greeted by Frances president and
Manuel Mackrell and his wife Brigitte
both leaders will deliver remarks that
will be followed by a moment of silence
and a 21-gun salute
they will then all walk through this
cemetery and participate in a
wreath-laying ceremony